In the range, Yukinoma t-san, light soy sauce, maker cup
sushi First, make the rice of Sochi in the first
place.  The rice is squeezed by people alone
so as not to break the rice. If you put a lot of effort into the rice, you wo
n't be able to cook the rice plumply. 4th or 5th
transfer  Even if you don't do anything, you can give the released rice to a colander and drain it.
I want you to wear a swimsuit to properly open the rice and water of that colleague.
Go cup rice and a certain cup of water Lick it.  I think that one of the hidden points is that the
rice rises cleanly by checking with the eyes how much it is boiling and then keeping the lid until what you
do.
Put the lid on and put it on low heat for about 15 minutes. If it was 15 minutes, turn off the heat
and leave it for 10 minutes from the right hand to steam the rice
.  When using it, I use black vinegar instead of sugar. It's
good for health and its taste is very refreshing. The
city uses fruits to drink instead of sugar. Add
mirin kelp to it.  Put the rice in it, mix it well, and then put it on the fire
. Stop it just before you stop it. When you stop it, put your feet on
it.
That's why, today, I'm going to make a foothold to restore it properly, and I'll make the needs of the person
.  I mix it while it's hot without shining. I often
say that it's rice with rice, but I don't need to meet at all
.
Today, I'm using the rice for the cup and ce, but the local tuna in Hawaii, the
Japanese hamachi sardine, and then the Japanese scallop rice, squid, squid, and squid.
There is a lot of water in the rice, but when it
comes in, it's called Diet.
Nowadays, even in countries all over the world, there is a foundation where there are Uchimura Japanese food lessons,
and now it is an era where the elements can be eaten easily, and the
way of thinking about prevention has changed.  The reason why I introduced the Katz people this time
is that I want them to be able to make beautiful and decent children at home and to make more sushi at home
.  I used it, but
if I do it at home, it's more like that. It doesn't matter if it's a player or a child's favorite Am.
Notifications and jobs
I became a cook when I was little
1 It's a sushi restaurant that my older brother Mali asked me to do.
I thought about becoming a sushi restaurant on the spot, and since then I
've been chasing after wanting to become a sushi restaurant, and even now I'm still in Sochi.
If you want to do it like that, first go on that path,
then do it and do it without knowing the failure of the 2nd system, always have a passion and take the customer's point of view
and cook. That is the most important thing.  Oes
[music]